gone put down the gun put down the gun
causes shooting brothers down put down
the gun
I empathize with all the victims of
police brutality and the killings that
have gone on and I was immediately
affected by it I mean this is my father
he was murdered in Texas my police
officer after after that I wrote free
and brave you know I kept pushing in the
way like never before
Star Spangled Banner he's just a
position of that pride but also
disappointment I felt not a pain but I
also felt empowered anyway but I was
like two people in there my heart
there's a high in my father not around
to my way like freedom gravis is like
yeah in spite of that what are you gonna
do are you gonna stop what you're gonna
let that hold you back
well people have free and brave I hope
people feel good a sense of liberation
that's where we are a desert
whenever we sing that we are stand firm
behind a house comes back to a place in
the song is her but I believe we are
free can manifest our destiny I think I
decided to twist it in another way and
my destiny manifested as well free and
brave is like a reminder for myself as I
continue on this path and that I can be
an exception breaking through barriers
is not always like sending roses with
some pain is about to come down with
frustrations happy